[Musique]
gunter pauli bonsoir bonsoir jours
seulement pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle singer view nous vous
recevrons dans votre cadre de sur
l'écologie sur l'anticipation certains
modèles économiques est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succinctement très
sexuellement ce que je suis belge avec
le japon j'étais enfant je parle cette
langue et j'adore
[Musique]
emmerder les gens
parce que vous pouvez détailler un peu
plus le côté je joue bien des gens le
côté très simple je propose des choses
qui sont quand même qui dérange c'est un
peu dans la philosophie de rené char
c'est
si vous venez au monde pour ne rien
troubler alors vous les mairies demi
patience ni regard alors c'est ça je
méritais regard parce que je dérange je
dérange je compliquer les choses parce
qu'on transforme la société sur ce que
nous avons besoin c'est une
transformation de la société les 30
sociétés ne se transforme pas si on rêve
on joue avec les règles du jeu
vous faites quoi pour changer les règles
du jeu a changé les règles c'est à dire
on a d'autres règles on joue selon ses
règles on est d'avis tu perds ce goliath
davidts il aurait joué comme goliath
alors le pauvre il n'aurait jamais
changé de l'histoire qui est de vite
qu'ils gullit david dont 7
ancien livre on parle de la vie de leur
folie at moi je suis le petit a vite
avec d'autres david et le goliath sont
aussi bien le gouvernement que les
grandes entreprises les institutions
scientifiques qui ne veulent pas changer
et alors là il faut que tout change ce
que vous avez un ami imaginaire
j'en ai beaucoup d'amis réels et
imaginaires nous croyons dieu mais je
suis bouddhiste
alors quand bouddhiste vous croyez que
c'est toujours possible de faire mieux
le plus important c'est la logique non
divisive qu'on ne dépense pas comme est
pour ou contre que c'est noir ou blanc
qu'on est chrétiens ou musulmans que non
non non non non ont tout le monde peut
toujours faire mieux c'est la
philosophie de la vie on a écouté une de
vos confiance il ya trois quatre
semaines c'est ça l'école polytechnique
vous étiez là 4 avril 4 avril départ
dont
il ya quelque chose qui m'a marqué et
qui m'a fait penser à un poème c'est le
renoncement de sap saint pierre qui se
termine pas je sortirai de ce monde où
l'action n'est pas sûr du rêve
vous êtes dans l'action vous êtes dans
le rêve allant des deux jamais la
division entre les deux c'est toujours
les deux ensemble c'est à dire ayant un
besoin est de rêver et de la vision et
de la fantasy et de faire tout pour
réaliser les rêves alors si on le fait
on passe on dépasse encore ce qu'on
imagine possible ce sont les grands
projets qu'on a pu réaliser sur des
projets ont fait mieux que ses rêves et
ça c'est grave ce qu'on appelle l'autre
poses des choses commencent à
fonctionner soi même vous avez chez vous
et u21 fontainebleau ses seins à oui
mais avant fonds tableau j'ai passé
quand même ses années chez les jésuites
12 du web et lendu les jésuites sont
d'extraordinaires professeurs si vous
êtes capable de répondre à leur niveau
d'exigence est si vous êtes capable de
survivre au niveau de stress qu'il vous
en poupe alors non ce pas de stress sur
l'abstrait s'il faut mieux pas aller
étudier chez eux le véhicule heures le
matin ah non j'étais en plus
je faisais la messe avec le matin alors
ce cisr admis 6h30 7h l'église et ses
terres et demi du petit déjeuner c'est
la ligne à l'époque bon vous vous
couchez avec une petite bière à ça
pourquoi un public br grande non non non
non je prends je préfère un bon vin je
suis belge mais je prends pas de verre
de bière ou très peu ma première
entreprise qui j'ai lancé au japon sur
l'exportation des bières des monastères
des abeilles et c'est comme ça que j'ai
démarré et c'est là où j'ai appris
comment fonctionne le marché le marché
était simple il y a beaucoup de demandes
le prix augmente il n'y a pas d'offre le
prix augmente encore plus on va rentrer
tout de suite dans le vif du sujet vous
êtes entrepreneur vous émettez des
possibilités de solutions concernant les
menaces que le 21e siècle nous réserve
comme la consommation énergétique qu'est
ce que vous pouvez me dire là dessus
c'est à dire que toutes les solutions
qu'on a aujourd'hui ne servent à rien
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est sur
une voie qui est trop coûteuse qui trop
compliqué qui est trop difficile
nous avons avec notre équipe nos
collègues on a mis un bateau sur l'eau
qui s'appellerait sur water la bateau on
a fait la preuve que si on a l'eau salée
l'eau de mer si on a
photovoltaïque on peut produire
hydrogène et avec les rejets notre
bateau 200 tonnes à une propulsion de
six jours si je mets la même force dans
les batteries lithium je n'ai qu'une
journée qu'ont commerce à vous écouter
de faire votre bateau 40 millions 50
millions d'euros 40 40 millions de
dollars tout roule pour les choses
d'accord vous avez une autonomie de six
jours pour 40 millions de dollars la
durabilité dessous de ce bateau c'est
quand même temps c'est la durabilité
c'est un bateau qui va tourner quand
même 50 ans
c'était prouver comment avant on est en
train de faire la preuve là c'est les
sciences est faire des sciences et pas
des lettres d'interdire oratoire mais la
première et du de la première
apprentissage qu'on a fait ce qu'on a
appris que si vous avez de lille me
c'est un jour si vous avez de
l'hydrogène avec la même énergie solaire
vous avez six jours alors pour moi ça
écarte immédiatement le lithium c'est
pour l'été cela qu'on
[Rires]
va revenir sur la viabilité de tesla un
peu après donc c'est une technologie qui
à base de panneaux solaires c'est ça
c'est panneaux solaires c'est le plus
simple durée de vie des panneaux
solaires comment la durée de vie de la
durée de vie des panneaux solaires bah
voilà jours on va le changer tout en
tout cas tous les trois-quatre ans parce
qu'on est on est je recherche de
l'efficacité alors il faut chercher
vérifier mais nous attendons que d'ici
trois quatre ans on est avec des
panneaux solaires bio avec des films en
bioplastique qu'on peut changer tout le
temps sans emmerder la terre
vous avez
produit vous avez un projet de produire
des protéines avec des algues et de
récupérer du gaz ce que vous nous en
parler un peu plus à mes protéines c'est
que l'être humain est à la recherche
pour se nourrir alors nous croyons que
la force qui vous a nou sé 38
organisations qui s'appelle série ou
bleu aux économies avec 3000 chercheurs
et plus ou moins 1000 entrepreneurs
alors on nous sommes un réseau des
réseaux scullion excuse une idéologie
danse résout pas des logis faire c'est
l'idéologie se transformer la société la
transformation se passe par faire et
apprendre et apprendre et apprendre et
faire mieux donc vous êtes opératif et
attendant souligné dessous ça c'est à
dire que nous acceptons que l'être
humain est leur aumône zapping non ça à
pioncer patente du tout ce qu'on veut
comment fonctionne ni la nature ni notre
corps ni l'espace et booth et dans ce
cas là il faut apprendre en faisant
des hug les algues alors les algues
c'est incroyable que nous sommes
capables de faire pousser mille tonnes
d'algues sur un hectare tandis qu'avec
des ogm on arrive à peine à 20 ans je
comprends pas les gens qui sont fascinés
par les ogm pour sauver le monde
parce que les ogm l'un porte rien du
tout qui sont en train de miner le
carbon de notre terre et c'est pour ça
que nous avons dû chercher des solutions
et bien entendu la nature et notre m la
nature nous enseigne que les algues
poussent vite avec milton parce que les
alpes ou sans 3d la cultive à sion est
normalement seulement sur 2d alors le
maïs sûrs d'eux des hommes les algues
sur 3d c'est évident avec une ère qui
est moins dense que l'eau que l'eau fait
pousser beaucoup plus mais
malheureusement le monde a décidé de
vider la mer de tout ce qui vit là
dedans et de le bourrer avec des
plastiques alors là on est un peu sur
une mauvaise voie
enfin on veut élargir un peu le prisme
de lecture on voudrait avoir votre avis
sur la fonction exponentielle la
fonction exponentielle c'est comme ça
qu'on se tue c'est le suicide
pourquoi devez être un arbre qui passe
d'une petite semences a dit m ne dis pas
qu'il va passer à 500 m c'est très bien
l'arbre à l'adn pour lui on sait l'adn a
enseigné que si on passe aussi vite on
compte unis croate pour papa voilà c'est
la suicide alors fonction exponentielle
ces suicides
vous proposer un modèle de soutenabilité
avec un impact sur la nature 1 0 ou très
faible sinon non pas 0 positif où il
faudra mettre la nature sur son
évolution naturelle sinon on ne récupère
pas tous les dégâts qu'on a fait alors
il faut être conscient qu'on a fait des
dégâts faut dire mais voilà ce sont des
accidents de parcours on accepte que
c'est vraiment des erreurs et
l'ignorance mais une fois que vous savez
que vous avez fait erreur il faut les
corriger et corrigé y inclus la
récupération
des dégâts vous devez remettre nature
sur son évolution et sur cette force de
symbiose n'est pas une dissonance
cognitive entre le fait de pouvoir
proposer
la protéine à bas coût de l'énergie à
bas coût je crois que le
mètre cube de gaz est beaucoup moins
cher avec votre production de d'algues
est-ce qu'il ya pas une dissonance
cognitive avec une société qui est
immature c'est à dire nous sommes une
société de transformant je vous donne un
exemple pour que vous c'est bien la
question en inde on propose une voiture
qui consomme beaucoup moins que
d'habitude chez tata
sa démocratise énormément la voiture et
se vend pas elle ne se vend pas à elle
se vend pas encore
ça démocratise énormément l'accès aux
transports est-ce que vos solutions ne
sont pas contre productive un moyen
terme mais celles ci ont que vous
mentionnez c'est pas une solution c'est
à dire que moi je propose dont plusieurs
de mes écritures élevé dans la pratique
il faut substituer quelque chose mais
rien du tout et c'est c'est la grande
différence alors je ne propose pas une
bagnole avec une autre bagnols la
bagnole qui est moins polluante être pas
loupé pour les world et c'est une
question de l'éthique soit vous acceptez
que vous êtes content or à faire moins
mal mais c'est pas la solution il faut
faire du bien et beaucoup plus du bien
et cet enjeu entre les deux c'est
exactement là il faut jouer avec
l'innovation
d'accord si vous proposez une énergie
moins chère
à une société transforme en caisse qui
se passe mais l'énergie moins cher vous
pensé au ribat effect c'est à dire que
c'est moins cher on va consommer plus
exactement mais ça ne s'est pas ça c'est
une une solution quand vous restez dans
la ligne arrêtée c'est une substitution
ont fait pas la substitution d'un
produit avec un autre on transforme la
société comment à parce que l'alg et
qu'on produit est une algue et ce sont
des algues en des milk les algues
produisent du gaz le gaz nous donne des
engrais les engrais nous donne humaira
culture et c'est évident que pour autant
que vous restez sur
le concept d'émission 0 on est rajoute
jamais un excédent de ce2 on va toujours
rassuré qu'il y à une meilleure
captation du co2 et du gaz méthane et
des autres dans ce cas là vous pouvez
accroître votre consommation
comment vous faites pour changer les
mentalités et les consciences des
peuples sur cette fonction exponentielle
d'hyperconsommation qu'on leur a
endoctriné qu'on leur a mis dans leur
tête depuis les 40 dernières années
voire 50 dernières années la seule
manière de faire changer les gens cèdent
à voir les gens dans un endroit un
espace qu'il considère un magasin de
jouets ils peuvent choisir les attendent
opportunités et tous les opportunités
qui sont là dedans sont des opportunités
que vont dans le bon sens si vous les
mettez sur devant la crise vous le
changez personnes des personnes
préfèrent l'hédonisme l'aujourd'hui est
pas le demain et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut le faire rêver et le rêver c'est
avec des cas concrets des choses qu'ils
ont vu qu'ils ont ressenti qu'il voit
quand les fêtes c'est possible de
générer un forêts tropicales en amazonie
et malheureusement on l'a fait il
aperçoit on a fait c'est à dire ah ouais
voilà on l'a vu en les conviant à
wimille mille hectares pour faire la
preuve
du premier lecteur sur combien détruits
ah non mais il faut toujours le premier
pas d'un bébé c'est le premier pas si
vous le passé fait le premier pas il
n'ya pas le deuxième alors c'est
exactement la honnelles ces échelles et
vitesse mais le premier pas le plus
important vous parlez de déchets les
deux vitesses je vais vous parler de
fréquence
la fréquence systémique des crises à ce
que nous ne sommes pas dans une
conjonction de crise écologique
financière énergétique et vega magique
qui nous impose de prendre vraiment en
considération le facteur temps est ce
que votre prisme de lecture n'arrive pas
un peu trop tard non vous avez confusion
entre le temps pour l'être humain et
pour la nature sont deux espaces de
temps dans la nature tout est certain
que la natation oui mais je tente de
l'entreprise et
c'est à dire dans la nature on a
toujours deux circulaires si vous êtes
bouddhiste vous créer dans la
réincarnation vous n'avez pas le stress
que vous avez si vous êtes catholique et
vous croyez que c'est la fin du monde
c'est là où il ya une différence
culturelle et que le chinois et les
asiatiques sont capable de confronter
les mêmes crises d'autres manières c'est
l'appréciation du temps et c'est pour ça
que c'est pour moi très important de
pouvoir travailler dans les différentes
cultures différentes sens mais la
réalité des choses c'est que j'ai
beaucoup plus de projets réalisés en
asie et en amérique latine en afrique en
europe parce que l'europe ne veut pas
changer et c'est pour ça que l'europe
continue décrié crise pour que l'on veut
peut changer à l'europe parce qu'on est
dans une bulle d'air qui était
reconditionnée
et comme on est dans une cellule air
conditionné vous voilà on trouve que
c'est quand même pas si mal à la fin de
la journée on a ces vacances on a quand
même l'éducation payer
on est qu'on a quand même pas une très
mauvaise santé mais on n'a pas le
bonheur comment vous gagnez rien vu rien
non pourquoi il faut gagner
il y avait il ya tant d'années que je
dise x de ce que j'ai c'est suffisant
elle offre ainsi un insuffisant ne
répond pas quand même se préoccuper
vous parliez de religion pour vous est
ce que les religions au 21ème siècle
sont encore nécessaires tout est
nécessaire selon les les créances des
gens c'est à dire que on peut pas c'est
comme les rois et les reines ce que
c'est encore nécessaire mais roi la
reine de voile à edel des gens qui ont
le besoin alors c'est pour ça qu'on ne
devrait pas l'interdire si les gens
ressentent un besoin spirituel
intellectuel
culturel d'avoir des rois ou des dieux
je le respecte
vous étiez catholiques ils vont dépasser
bouddhiste m'a bien entendu alors les
jésuites me rends jamais accepté ni
d'entrer dans l'église si je n'étais
baptisé confirmés et avec 2 et reste je
ne suis pas mariée devant l'église vous
parler latin non alea jacta nuit alors
oui alea jacta est ça vous fait passer
un prochain coin à quoi alea jacta est
les dés sont jetés
vous vous imaginez où et comment dans
dix ans moi je ne sais pas je m'imagine
nulle part je vis je vis aujourd'hui le
moment même c'est ça ce qui compte parce
que c'est le moment même c'est le seul
qui est la vérité la race tu sais ce
sont des possibilités
les gouvernements vous accueille comment
est ce qui vous regarde d'un oeil
comme un gourou est-ce qu'il vous
regarde comme un un illuminé ce qui vous
regarde comme un entrepreneur ou comme
info lumineux
non c'est à dire qu'il y à des
gouvernements qui bien entendu en tan
intérêt de faire réaliser une
transformation etc l
argentine chili le roi de boutons sont
des gens qui souhaitent avoir des idées
claires et concrètes de transformation
dans leur société et s'il y a vraiment
un désir politique qui est confirmé par
des actions alors je suis là je
participe avec
notre grande équipe qui présents autour
du monde vous êtes rémunéré pour ça
l'organisation rémunérés ça veut pas
dire que gunter pauli rémunérés sont
polis facture à l'organisation non il ne
facture pas je facture jamais je peux
pas je ne signe pas de contrat il faut
qu'on me mettre être aujourd'hui dans un
état d'esprit qui est tout à fait
différent vous écoute de thé l'esprit
c'est que je suis au service de cette
terre il y à des organisations qui nous
aide mais bien entendu ce que j'ai même
pose à moi je peux pas imposer à tout le
monde qu'est ce que vous vous imposez
vous à d'être au service du monde vous
mangez de la viande ah oui bien entendu
je ne dirais pas mais
j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'enfant mais bien entendu
mais la viande que je que je connais je
mange pas la viande que je connais pas
c'est à dire que si je ne connais pas la
poule je ne mange pas
si je sais c'est évident parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait avec les
pauvres animaux c'est impossible alors
c'est important d'avoir une vue sur la
réalité des choses et décider ce que je
mange mange pas je ne prends pas du lait
de vache mais debré beewi parce que là
on n'est pas capable de mettre les
hormones et les des produits
synthétiques comme on le souhaite
prenez l'avion ou mais bien entendu 300
fois par an qu'est ce que vous faites
pour compenser un prix de la terre non
j'ai déjà compenser la totalité de tout
ce qui est ma vie multiplie person
comment à en pl en s'aimant des arbres
je dirige est quand même le plus grand
projet de reforestation d'amérique
latine et alors je crois que c'est un
domaine indispensable de le faire avant
comprennent d'avion pas parce qu'on
prend l'avion et c'est ça la prévision
dont l'un a besoin d'eux avec le projet
d'algues on parle quand même des
milliers de tonnes qui sont capturés
dans les algues parce que si vous faites
la collecte de 1000 tonnes d'algues il
ya toujours cinq cents tonnes d'algues
qui reste dans le maire quand vous voyez
des initiatives françaises comme la cap
21 ça vous fait penser à coincer argent
perdu du wishful thinking non argent
perdu j'ai été à la base j'étais dans
l'équipe de la création du du kyoto du
protocole de kyoto alors j'ai participé
à la demande de japonais à la demande
des nations unies j'ai participé dans
les préparations du protocole ce que
j'ai proposé n'est pas acceptée mais
j'ai vu que le multilatéralisme
c'est une méthode d'arriver à un
consensus est une extraordinaire idées
dont les années 80 90 mais aujourd'hui
c'est fini ça ne fonctionne pas il faut
arriver avec la démocratie là où sont
les citoyens n'oublions pas que le nom
est citoyen c'est la cité qui est à la
base pas on n'est pas national on est
citoyen et c'est pour ça que je trouve
que c'est si important qu'on remette la
démocratie à ce niveau d'un bon feu à
faire des projets sur cet état y dire
qu'on ne fait pas par exemple
l'argentine ou en chili fait pas des
projets chiliens ont fait des projets à
mag la neige dans le sud on fait des
projets a pas nourries ont fait des
projets à tubes août ont fait là où il
ya des gens et on ne tente pas du tout
de faire des projets une chaîne
nationale
quand je suis en france je préfère faire
des projets à haut rhin en alsace que
devenir la france
quand on m'a préparé cette émission on a
eu des échos que vous êtes si beaucoup
dans le greenwashing
des gens qui ne vous aimez pas qu'est ce
que vous pouvez leur répondre parce
qu'il m'a j'adore mes critiques qui vous
le dit quand ils vous disent que vous
êtes un escroc du greenwashing une
pointe de diamant de des chefs
d'entreprise qui vous utilisent pour
faire avaler la pilule alors moi je ne
connais ni un entrepreneur renier une
entreprise qu'il a fait non pas la
chance de le faire mais c'est normal que
quand on dérange qu'on a des critiques
et je les reçois volontiers parce que ça
me renforce dans ma mission sur mais
twitter si vous le suivez vous verrez
régulièrement
remerciements des remerciements aux
personnes qui me critique qui même bête
qui meurt m'appelle des et
cetera c'est fantastique parce que ça me
confirme que je suis sur la bonne voie
vous connaissez le vieil adage de jeu de
gandhi si je crois bien non je voulais
ce que commencer
au départ ils vont vous critiquez après
vous vous combattre après vous gagnez
c'est ça après on va apprécier ensemble
pour faire beaucoup plus
parce que vous connaissez les travaux de
pablo serving non est ce que vous pouvez
est ce que vous êtes penché sur
l'effondrement systémique mais bien
entendu mais je vois suis un fanatique
de maths orana j'étais encore avec
umberto maternelle de semaine dernière
avec varela je suis j'ai quand même
écrit un livre avec frites chauve capra
c'est à dire que harness est un de nos
grands inspirateurs
alors la réflexion systémique est à la
base de toutes nos actions
vous avez vous fait toujours partie du
club de rome je suis membre de comité
exécutif en plus personne n'est parfait
le club de rome nous annonce
des choses très difficiles
vous êtes le seul à annoncer des choses
positif au saint louis mais le club de
rome en 72 ils ont fait leur rapport à
ta la croissance par après on a fait pas
mal d'autres rapports il ya en totalité
44 rapport il y a deux rapports qui sont
positifs entre autres l'économie bleus
qui fut approuvé en 2009
mais aujourd'hui l'économie bleus est le
deuxième rapport le plus circulé
du club de rome et on vient de sortir en
un livre qui s'appelle common en anglais
c'est un livre qui ramassent quand même
une quarantaine d'initiatives qui sont
prises par les membres du club de rome
et ont fait la preuve que le club de
rome et dans une transformation la
transformation de la réflexion long
terme à l'action qui transforme à long
terme
est ce que votre modèle
prévoit
de la croissance un effet de plateau une
décroissance tous ensemble parce qu'il y
a des gens qui doit faire la
décroissance dans l autre à nous
européens
les américains pour favor
los gringos ce
c'est obligatoire qu'ils vont avoir la
décroissance mais on peut pas dire dans
les favelas au brésil qu'il faut avoir
un peu de décroissance c'est pas
possible il faut avant tout comme on
nous le disons toujours répondre aux
besoins de base tout le monde qui se
chiffrent en calories un combinant par
tête de pipe ça dépend parce que la
galerie c'était malheureusement un
paramètre trop simplifié pour expliquer
j'ai besoin du yacht plus que de
protéines ci n'est pas diodes ça
fonctionne pas alors protéines ça suffit
pas je crois que les 2000 qu'on propose
aujourd'hui c'est exagéré on peut se
satisfaire avec 600 800 à condition
qu'on a finalement dit y être plus
balancée et qui ne dépend pas seulement
des protéines
d'accès à l'énergie qui va déterminer ce
seuil est ce que les populations
occidentales ne vont pas continuer
à être en guerre contre 1,7 pour cette
croissance
comment vous allez faire passer votre
message auprès des mouvements
les gouvernements c'est là je démarre
pour la transformation là où les septs
sites sont en train de déranger tous les
systèmes alors l'allemagne continue à
susciter le charbon aujourd'hui 2018
c'est inacceptable chili continue à
subsidier le gaz naturel importé de la
russie alors je travaille là où les
subsides et les dégâts environnementales
sont si vastes que c'est assez facile de
proposer des alternatives les gaz de
schiste le fracking
ne s'est pas concurrencer contre le gaz
des algues et c'est çà ou là où il ya
les subsides et là il est vraiment
insisté le substitut
subventions pendant des mois ils ne la
lit à des subventions
j'interviens en changeant le système
parce que quel est le problème du gaz
naturel c'est qu'on fait les engrais
avec du gaz naturel alors aujourd'hui on
est capable de montrer qu'elle est
parfaitement possible avec 12000
kilomètres carrés de mer de deux
territoires maritimes de l'argentine on
est parfaitement capable de substituer
la totalité de l'importation de
l'argentine avec 12000 kilomètres carrés
ils ont trois millions trois cent c'est
certes du fâ rien les états unis la
totalité de la nécessité de d'énergie
aux états unis on peut le remplacer avec
650 mille kilomètres carrés aujourd'hui
ils ont 3 5 millions de kilomètres
carrés de maïs alors ce pas difficile
c'est faisable est ce que l'économie
bleue ou verte c'est une question
internet parce que l'économie bleue ou
verte n'est pas encore un moyen de
continuer un modèle capitalistique ah
non si on veut ne veut pas et on a
besoin de fric c'est à dire qu'on va pas
rentrer dans le système il n'y a pas de
fric iso pour autant qu'on a besoin
d'argent il faut savoir comment
travaille avec cet argent et ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on a un système capitaliste
traditionnel féroce comme on a
aujourd'hui mais ça veut dire qu'on a
besoin
d'identifier où circulent comme ans
circule d'argent en plus si on a une
bonne idée comment circulent argent on
peut avoir des effets dans le système de
rétro l'aimantation de multiplicateurs
c'est à dire on va plus vite grâce à
l'argent qui circule plus vite et pas à
l'accumulation de l'argent dans des
poches du compte bancaire de 100
personnes
vous parlez de la concentration de
pouvoirs je vais vous parler de
d'opposition des grandes multinationales
comment total shell et sous et j'en
passe vous regarde ce qu'ils vous ont
mis des tueurs serbe derrière votre
chambre est ce que vous les menaces et
ce qu'ils vous ont proposé de collaborer
ce qu'ils vous ont tendu la main alors
on fait tout pour bâle moment c'est à
moi de faire le choix c'est à dire selon
la culture de l'entreprise je souffre je
fais le choix c'est évident que shell
m'a vite pape dans le conseil
d'administration c'est normal je
comprends
mais c'est de l'autre côté je suis
partenaire avec une société que je
préside nous sommes le partenaire avec
emi en italie c'est à dire que c'est pas
dit ici des s'imaginer qu'on rejoint
symbiose synergie entre les deux à
condition qu'on accepte la
transformation vous avez cet enfant
c'est ça 6-6 bas 7e si vous êtes au
courant des mois les détails
vous j'en parle à vous de faire je
m'appellerai ce soir
est ce que vous êtes pour une contrôle
de la démographie la démographie tout
dépend de l'éducation de qualité de la
vie qu'on sait offrir c'est un choix
personnel je ne crois pas du tout que
c'est un gouvernement qui a la droit de
décider pour le reste du pays si vous
pouvez avoir un ou deux enfants j'ai eu
la liberté la grande liberté pas
seulement liberté mais grande liberté
d'avoir le luxe de me procurer six
enfants dont une est adopté alors je
crois que la vie c'est la vie et on fait
son mieux et je crois que ce sont des
décisions personnelles
en ce moment il ya un mouvement mondial
qui est d'arrêter de faire des gamins à
thé de faire des enfants pour préserver
la terre est-ce que vous avez un opinion
dessus est ce que vous avez amelia
d'autres qui ils font tout ce qu'ils
investissent tout leur argent pour avoir
un bébé alors on a les deux c'est à dire
que je crois que c'est important que le
renouvellement cellulaire qui est
incertain miracle n'oublions pas que six
mois à 62 ans j'ai un autre enfant les
cellules qui naissent avec sept enfants
sont des cellules vierge alors lié à une
sorte de nettoyage naturel qui se fait
en criant un enfant et la société on a
besoin sinon on est bourré des vieux
comme ce sera le cas du japon
ce qui n'est pas durable c'est pas
soutenable et je crois que c'est pour
cette raison là il faut avoir
pas une solution pour le monde mais il
faut savoir et la décision personnelle
et les régions on en est pour s'imaginer
la meilleure forme c'est les multitudes
de petites décisions qui vont faire la
différence dans une société mondialisée
sa fonction de ça évidemment vous
décidez d'en de 2,2 d'offrir à facebook
tous vos données vous le décidez tous
les jours vous répéter tout le temps
alors ça veut dire que nous avons
l'opportunité de prendre de faire des
choix si on fait le choix oui ou non
consciemment oui ou non c'est autre
chose mais l'opportunité est encore là
je vois pas bien le parallélisme entre
les données personnelles et faire des
enfants annonce le plus personnel quand
même chez les enfants et les données
c'est à dire que on a les deux c'est
très personnel et si je prends des
décisions les décisions autour de ma
personne aujourd'hui qui m'a fait que le
plus c'est évidemment pour le long terme
l'information que vous partager sur
facebook parce que ça veut peut venir
contre vous comme c'est le cas avec pas
mal personne et deuxièmement la décision
que vous prenez pour avoir un enfant oui
ou non ça n'influence commun sur votre
vie donc au niveau de la maturité des
peuples
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur le taux ni
personnel et il la production
démographique est ce que vous comprenez
ma question
aujourd'hui on a décidé nous chacun
individuellement qu'en revanche d'une
adresse e-mail on partage tout ce qu'on
fait tous les jours avec le big data
alors cinq entreprises contrôlent 80% de
cette information
incroyable quand on était possible de
faire ça et dans ce contexte là les
décisions que nous prenons pour voir des
enfants oui ou non l'éducation qu'on
donne la philosophie qu'on apporte les
défis qu'on lance tout ça 2 revient dans
un grand pot qui aujourd'hui a vendu des
entreprises pour le feu lancé la pub je
crois que ont finalement on commence à
se rendre compte de ce qu'on a fait pour
cette adresse gratuite et l'adresse
gratuite enfin c'était très piégeur
c'était une bonne idée ex trente
concepts d'affaires mais ça ne m'apporte
rien du tout dans notre capacité de
prendre des décisions à propos ni de
notre futur ni de notre bonheur
sur les enfants les enfants les enfants
aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on fait autour de
nos enfants ce sont des décisions
personnelles mais ce casque une femme
africaine qui a besoin de cet enfant
pour pouvoir assurer ses vieux jours
elle n'en a pas besoin c'est une idée
économique des du nord nous avons
expliqué à ces femmes que pour survivre
comme un mille oeuvres alors sur les six
que les explications des européens les
cultures traditionnelles ne sont pas du
tout tous et toutes dans cette logique
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de mieux
comprendre comment fonctionne nature
dans la nature il y attend des décisions
qui sont prises naturellement ou n'a pas
besoin ni de la philosophie ni de la
logique
catholique européenne
c'est quoi des décisions prises
naturellement peinture à la nature
décide que selon la disponibilité de la
nature on à une procréation oui ou non
alors s'il n'y a pas de nourriture les
cafards ne vont pas du tout approprié
ils attendent jusqu'au moment qui la
nature et de la nourriture sont quand
même l'édition assez intéressante et
sont pas les seuls les pingouins qu'on
ya trop de pingouins il se met à l'eau
ils vont se suicider des décisions qui
sont prises alors lié à une certaine
logique dans la nature ces événements là
où nous sommes différents nous sommes
des êtres humains on peut faire la
réflexion et nous avons la créativité
que nous permet d'élargir mes horizons
d'offrir des opportunités qu'on ne se
connaissait pas les fourmis de feu
contient pas assez de nourriture elles
vont se projeter chez les copains elle
mange tout chez les copains
ah oui mais le cannabis mais existait
aussi chez nous c'est à dire que il faut
quand même pas me avoir des opinions
positives négatif le bon la malle dire
qu'il faut faire mieux et c'est ça ce
qui me m'inspire toujours quand je suis
en afrique où j'ai nous avons quand même
pas mal projet zimbabwe ghana
bénin
on est actif en afrique dans l'afrique
du sud si on est là et nos actifs on
sait bien que les opportunités de
l'afrique sont extraordinaires mais pas
selon le modèle économique on était un
peu osée et certainement pas avec
l'agriculture qu'on a imposé j'ai besoin
d'un peu d'eau ça commence à venir
s'assécher un peu aussi bien comment son
nom mais on est dans le vif du sujet
comment vous expliquez que la chine
revendique la mer de chine de l'accord
dans l'es7 trait est ce que vous pensez
que les conflits géopolitiques se
détendre avec votre votre modèle quand
tout le monde reconnaît qu'ils sont
capables de répondre à leurs besoins de
base on les relax max mais le moment
qu'on ressent quand on n'est pas capable
de répondre aux besoins de base c'est là
que ça y est
est-ce que vous pensez que les alarmes
l'inertie
de ces 100 dernières années va pouvoir
se concilier avec votre modèle je ne
cherche pas une réconciliation avec mon
modèle je n'ai pas un modèle je suis
dans un état évolutif des possibilités
c'est comme de jouvenel la plaine et
futuribles nous sommes dans les
futuribles nous sommes dans des
multiples possibilités et il faut comme
un mets recherché pas une solution mais
des solutions et c'est dans cet esprit
là que je crois que nous aurons
d'énormes possibilités de changer des
normes vous écoute
tu prends un verre
prenons notre petit cas du café
alors bien son pays dans le monde qui
exportait café le prix du café est un
prix bradé ce que les paysans les cafés
culture ne savent pas survivre avec le
café alors qu'est-ce qu'on a inventé
nous capitalistes européens on a inventé
le café juste le café de série max
havelaar et voilà on va payer 20 30%
plus c'est pas la solution avec 20 ou
30% plus on ne sauve pas du tout les
familles on n'a pas du tout une
alternative
de répondre aux besoins pour l'éducation
pour la nourriture pour la santé etc et
c'est là où vraiment on intervient dans
la réflexion comment ce qu'on change ce
modèle or le début notre modèle c'était
de faire mes champignons sur le mark a
fait et les champignons des déchets les
déchets de champion c'est pour la pole
alors voilà on a trois revenus au lieu
d'un revenu et on utilise la totalité du
café au lieu de seulement consommer à
gérer le virgule 2% maintenant nous
sommes dans d'autres modèles beaucoup
plus avancé quand on regarde la valeur
la chaîne de la valeur qu'ils aient crié
avec le café on constate qu'il y à
naître mais dierkes irresponsable pour
la torréfaction
et un multiple de 4
fascinant petit service multiplie par
quatre c'est pour ça que nous avons mis
des ingénieurs là dessus maintenant on a
la fameuse machine
expresso pour la maison qui fait la
torréfaction et le café ou maman quels
avantages qu'aujourd'hui en achète le
café vert direct des calculs terre quand
on achète du café direct on demande au
consommateur de payer le même prix
qu'ils payent avant ça veut dire x 4
c'est à dire aujourd'hui avec les
premiers 1500 café culteurs qui n'ont
qu'une petite hectares qui normalement
n'a pas accès à ce marché on sait faire
la découverte de la torréfaction alors
la machine nous donne aujourd'hui grâce
à un apps avec toute la communication
de qr code ci dévient fille ne donne les
décisions de cent mille consommateurs
sur la torréfaction on est devenu le
plus grand banques de données sur la
torréfaction à la maison c'est
exactement ce que souhaitent les gens
alors c'est ça la création de la
nouvelle banque de données big data sur
la torréfaction qui était site la
consommation n'est ce café nespresso
lavazza signé les autres et on ne vont
pas l'information c'est notre
information mais ça nous permet de faire
nous espérons d'ici dix ans en dix et
vingt ans avec les cafés ce qu'ont les
bordelais ont fait avec le board où il
ya des châteaux
coude outre
une fois qu'on est dans cet esprit du
big data et on est dans l'esprit de
faire cette plus value il faut
travailler la logistique parce que la
logistique et les plus importants le
deuxième qui gagne d'argent avec la
mondialisation de la globalisation ce
sont les gens responsables pour la
logistique alors on il faut le
perfectionner améliorée
aujourd'hui on a fait des comme
aujourd'hui on fait l'importation du
café vert on n'a pas du tout besoin de
l'emballage avec aluminium plastique etc
on enlève tout cela on le fait don des
1000 melita l'ancien melita vous
rappeler on en est là dans un petit
carton enveloppe dans l'envoi par voie
fedex dans des containers ils ont fait
un conteneur entier ça veut dire que
quand ça arrive à berlin on la met dans
la poste et la post allemande le livre
ce sont les idées sont simples
l'exécution est compliqué bien entendu
qui n'est pas content ceux qui sont l'un
des intermédiaires les torréfacteurs
n'aime pas du tout ils ont perdu le
marché c'est celle là exactement là où
faut agir l'industrie pétrolière va
quand même levé vous levée des boucliers
vos modèles
l'industrie pétrolière les sept soeurs
est ce que ça vous parle
je m'inquiète pas du tout deux des
pétrolières je n'aime je m'inquiète pas
du tout
je crois qu'ils ont assez de problèmes à
résoudre avec leur actionnariat qu'ils
vont se préoccuper de mes propositions
les gars les producteurs de gaz se
préoccupe de mes propositions des algues
là je sais mais si on fait la
comparaison il ya d'autres produits qui
dérange où nous sommes actifs comme par
exemple avec l'automate à la production
de tomates vous connaissez notre projet
voilà
jusqu'à présent quand on a des tomates
ont fait pousser des tomates on a besoin
d'eau nous avons fait la première grande
production de tomates ou les tomates
produisent lot pour chaque kilo tomates
on a 3 litres 5 litre d'eau on change
complètement le modèle alors si vous
avez un terrain qui ne vaut rien qui ait
bord de la mer ou ne rien ne pousse il
n'y a pas d'eau potable il n'y a pas
d'électricité on dit achetons ce terrain
n'achète le terrain ont fait pousser des
tomates mais on prend l'eau froide de la
mer toujours moins froides - 20 mètres
et ont fait circuler et on change le
point d'heure de rose âge comment ceux
ci ont souvent tendance à sion alors on
va pousser la contestation la con de
séance et si bonne que si fait plus
chaud n'a plus de confiance on a
beaucoup plus de condensation
aujourd'hui on produit dix sept mille
tonnes de tomates cette manière c'est ça
ce qu'il faut mais la distribution
la production est à 1800 et 2400 km de
melbourne en australie de melbourne
sydney mais d'imola alors là votre prix
tomates serait impossible mais non on
n'y a pensé parce que si vous êtes au
bout du monde tous les camions qui
passent par porte agosta où nous sommes
installés tous les camions pour ta
gauche ta part tu vide on april y a 10
en option sur la totalité des camions
vides et c'était combien 17 mille tonnes
alors maintenant ils partent complet on
est capable de faire du des tomates bio
la moitié du prix qu'ils sont mis sur le
marché à melbourne et assaini c'est ça
la logique économique ça s'est joué avec
sept marchés et de rompre la logique qui
sont comme des logiques du passé ce sont
des gens qui ont des ennemis et qui font
ça qui font ces calculs nous faisons là
calcul qu'on enseignait pas me aline
seat
vous entendre c'est magnifique
on a une question mais j'ose à vis de
venir visiter parce que si vous visitez
pas vous vous imaginez que cette affaire
fallu non non non non non on voit tout à
fait le principe on a une question pas
de vous servir
qui est incollable solorgues quelqu'un
qui qui qui selon jm jarre est de guérir
est du genre alors vous qui connaissez
bien les pays du sud croyez vous qu'il
est possible de continuer à pomper des
métaux et produire du béton comme nous
le faisons mais peut-on vraiment
imaginer une croissance sans ces
matériaux tout en fixant du carbone
évidemment si c'est possible c'est ma
fantasy c'est ma vision et au lieu
d'avoir le breton comme même la
construction en amérique latine et en
asie s'est fait surtout par les gens
intelligents c'est dire les pauvres avec
le bambou il y à un milliard de gens qui
vivent dans des immeubles bamboo alors
le bambou c'est le béton végétal ce
existe ça pousse ça fonctionne et sa
capture le co2 c'est pour ça que j'ai
lancé il y a déjà 20 ans la grande
campagne pour le bambou ou question
quels sont les changements concrets
qu'importer l'économie bleus est ce que
le changement est ce que les changements
vont assez vite ou est-ce que ça sent le
roussi c'est toujours trop lents
toujours trop lents passe jamais assez
vite mais ça vous le donne l'énergie
pour aller à l'air un peu vite c'est
comme une bonne course quand même le
marathon nous savons très bien on ne
fait pas le 100 m ont fait des marathons
fait des triathlons ça veut dire qu'il
faut comme m
être respectueux pour le corps et pas
donné toute la force la première journée
mais je crois que surtout dans les pays
du tiers-monde
la
disponibilité la capacité de changer et
de s'y adapter est énorme
quelle différence avec la permaculture
ou avec le biomimétisme
alors j'adore la permaculture la
permaculture je connaissais bien bill
mollison le fondateur avec une petite
différence la permaculture et dont le
monde des faune flore et minéraux
plainte
et nous sommes dans le monde des cinq
royaumes de la nature ça veut dire que
je travaille avec la permaculture en
incertain les micro algues et en
incertain surtout les champignons pour
le reste même philosophie biomimétisme
alors
je faisais partie de l'équipe de janine
benyus il y a vingt ans pour le bm et
métis mme j'adore le biais mimétisme et
je n'aime pas du tout les billets métis
mais des espèces moi je suis le
fanatique et du billet minutes is
l'écosystème ou est ce que tous jouent
ensemble quelle est la réglementation
qui a besoin qui coule ce sont le
symbiose c'est ce qui m'intéresse
lorsque à la fin de la journée c'est que
le velcro on est tous le velcro est une
imitation de la nature mais on le fait
avec une plastique qui est quand même
une plastique polluantes
la nature ne ferais jamais ça la nature
sera toujours consciente que le produit
le procédé est le système les trois sont
intégrés alors le biomimétisme intégrée
des écosystèmes
fasciné
est-ce que vous avez un avis sur la zad
de notre dame des landes où les gens
tentent un modèle de société
le quoi je suis désolé madame lansade se
dire zone à défendre un autre de
notre-dame-des-landes c'est
zones humides qu'ils étaient protégés
par des gens oui contre un aéroport
ouais c'est vrai aussi qu'il faut être
contre les rapports c'est évident qu'il
faut le faire
pourquoi pourquoi parce qu'il faut quand
même
dans comme dans la nature comme ailleurs
il faut avoir des frontières des
frontières naturelles et une fois et
dans un temps deux fois trois fois il
faut dire arrêtons ici et alors je crois
que l'art est important et l'avion
l'avion là report c'est une belle
invention du 19ème 20ème siècle mais
aujourd'hui il faut quand même passer au
delà de ça et c'est inventer autre chose
votre modèle de société parce que ça
s'apparente plus ou vénus project
quelque chose qui traînent sur internet
est-ce que ça s'apparente à quelque
chose de plus pacifié comment comment
vous gérer tout ça mais
dès le moment que votre but est de
répondre aux besoins des gens avec ce
que vous avez vous auriez une
pacification le problème c'est qu'on
désire avoir n'importe quoi n'importe où
et n'importe quel prix pour les gens qui
puissent se le permettre alors c'est
évident qu'on est dans une collusion
géopolitique c'est l'un de ces nature
même de cette désir et cette liberté de
se permettre ce qu'on veut quand on veut
vous tuer
évidemment je vote vous descoings je
veux toujours pour les cils à
l'indépendant toujours pour les
indépendants s'il n'ya pas toujours pour
les verts
mais heureusement heureusement il y a
beaucoup d'indépendants aujourd'hui
ce que vous êtes inquiet pas un petit
peu ou racine même du capitalisme de la
cour la consommation frénétique mais je
suis bien entendu coupable d'avoir
partagé participer dans cela c'est
l'évidence même je suis un être humain
et je prends trois cents fois par an le
les avions alors c'est évident que je me
préoccupe quelles sont les solutions
qu'elle autre manière je pourrais
utiliser c'est la force quand même
d'avoir ce qu'on appelle un en espagnol
de spectacle
impeccable
since
non sinon c'est
non alors là oublions pas sont deux
signes si j'ai fait quelque chose de mal
il faut dire péché je suis comme un
pêcheur comme tout le monde on est dans
le monde dont ces critères on est
pêcheur vous battez pour vous six
enfants
mais surtout en créant des opportunités
et on l'aide défiant de le faire
difficile de temps en temps parce que
les enfants l'ont trop facile
aujourd'hui j'ai les amène mes enfants
mes fils dès qu'ils ont dix ans je les
amène pas d'une heure
non au nord 1er janvier 7 janvier
patente rien du tout on va d être avec
les samis pour apprendre à survivre si
elle ouvert alors bien entendu ça fait
du mal aux pieds ça fait mal dit ça fait
mal à moins 6 mais après ils ont
redéfini ce qu'est la douleur
il faut apprendre dans la vie ce qui est
la douleur fut votée du question
jésuites qui parle bah oui peut-être ce
soit mon côté qu' il faut quand même
redéfinir les frontières de la logique
et de nos sens
comment vous faites pour redéfinir la
frontière de vos sens à l'avoir aidé un
peu non
comment prenais de la drogue un peu
jamais jamais fait de la méditation non
jamais pas de dotation de matni messiaen
si je veux mais dit et pensé j'écris je
suis un écrivain je mets à écrire et ça
ça continue ça vient alors pour moi la
méditation c'est l'écriture mais je fais
tous mes écritures sur le tatami
j'habite tatami connaissez
que 1 comment comment vous allez à
imposer je n'impose pas comment vous
avez proposé à une population qui dans
une catatonique notionnels est dans le
déni
un changement de société on chante on
raconte des fables il faut quand même
trouver une manière d'arriver à
motiver et inspirer connectés c'est la
connexion mais connexion pas là là le
coeur et la connexion se fait avec oi
avait été belle histoire
les blacks raconte une belle histoire à
une belle histoire c'est que c'est un
arbre qui se demande comment il peut
être le plus fort de la terre ou de ce
fort est cet arbre se pose la question
et dit même quand même si j'ai beaucoup
plus de feuilles j chlorophylle alors
avec le soleil j'ai beaucoup plus
d'énergie ici plus d'énergie je serai
plus fort mais si j'ai plus de feuilles
alors en automne je vais les perdre
alors les perdre ça veut dire que le
champignon les bactéries les insectes
tout le monde va avoir beaucoup plus à
manger grâce à moi mais mes failles mais
alors ils vont me préparer du mucem
sujet plus d'humus alors moi j'aurai
plus de deux fleurs sujet plus de fleurs
via plus d'abeilles ici a + b i j'aurais
de plus de fruits ici j'ai plus de
fruits il ya beaucoup plus de deux
oiseaux qui vont visiter les oiseaux
vont me laisser leurs excréments que
j'adore parce que là lui mu est enrichi
si avec la pluie est alors moi je serai
le plus fort je vais vraiment être les
plus forts la brs rencontre qu'il n'est
que le plus fort s'il donne aux autres
ce qu'il n'y a plus besoin mais qu'il
reçoit de cadeaux sont le demandent et
des autres ce que les autres ont fait
pour l'arbre mais l'arbre à un problème
n'aime pas les vers de terre déteste les
vers de terre les détestent parce qu'il
n'a jamais osé demander quelle est la
queue qu'elle la tête et communales je
me demander quel est votre que quel est
votre tête ne déteste c'est pour ça que
quand même avec sa force d'arbres il
pourrait renvoyer tous les vers de terre
mais il sait très bien c'est un jour et
renverrait tous les vers de terre serait
jamais l'arbre le plus fort du forez
est-ce que vous avez identifié des
mouvements en france qui vont vendre
dans qui vont dans votre sens c'est à
dire j chaque français va d'ancêtres
sens parce que tout le monde souhaite le
bonheur est ce que l'on faisait bonheur
qu'est ce que vous pensez du nucléaire
le nucléaire c'est du passé c'est un bon
exercice dans le passé world obligé de
vivre avec encore 50 ans et avec les
déchets encore quarante mille en
erreur de parcours voilà et on apprend
même la france commence assez fermé ses
centres nucléaires l'année prochaine la
première à fessenheim alors d'azad ils
vont fermer la première et les autres
vont suivre comme on va payer on paye en
créant des plus values avec autre chose
c'est qu'on me l'a toujours fait dans la
vie c'est qu'on fait la nature s'il y a
un incendie d'un côté la nature on va
créer d'autres vie ailleurs et c'est ça
ce qu'il faut faire c'est le systémiques
celles interconnectés on ne peut pas
balancer les choses dans le système de
l'aide du nucléaire il faut sortir de la
cuillère et par exemple il faut avoir la
force et la clarté comme il paraît en
alsace et ils ont pour dire mais voilà
nous serons premiers régions de la
france qui est 100% énergies
renouvelables ce que les énergies
renouvelables
l'énergie la seule énergie qui est
vraiment renouvelables est autour de
nous ça dépend soleil vent et eau si
vous aimez les trois ça fonctionne vous
avez un background économistes oui je
suis j'ai formé comme économique
si vous pouvez nous dire de quelle est
votre perception du système économique
actuel sur la production de liquidité
sur les plans de relance comme le
quantitative easing comme les ailes t en
ou qu'est ce que vous en pensez quoi
c'est l'équivalent d'injecter un peu de
liquidités a avoué la fameuse
easing que font les banques
vous savez que ce que beaucoup
d'économistes ont perdu de vue c'est que
toute intervention
macroéconomique la pâte sens si on ne
change pas le micro et le micro c'est le
modèle d'affaires comment je gagne mon
argent avec mon épée série comment je
gagne mon argent avec mon café comment
je le fais avec ma lampe à lumière mon
internet ma connexion alors
seul change que je crois qu'avec une
miss qui est viable
ce sont des changements qu'on réalise
sur dans le micro et ça c'est
l'innovation l'innovation pas de la
technologie mais l'innovation du modèle
d'affaires et une fois qu'on a réussi de
changer des modèles d'affaires très vite
il y a un casque aad effet de cascade
qui va changer les maquereaux mais
malheureusement on a des grands macro
économiste qui sont au pouvoir et qui
ont les grands mots à dire et ce sont
eux qui aujourd'hui font ça mais pour
moi c'est par le vent qu'est-ce qu'on
fume ou lui prend l'élite où son goût de
new york péter manoj demande que en
général je demande qu'il passe une nuit
en prison
une nuit pas plus une wii pour faire une
méditation forcé et de ressentir quelle
est la dui vraiment des gens qu'ils ne
font plus part de notre société
alors c'est là où je crois que c'est
important
une nuit pas plus peut plus simple mais
dans quelle prison de fleury mérogis
anneaux je connais pas
ps j'adore je n'ai jamais passé une nuit
dans une prison alors peut-être il faut
qu'on me fasse avec moi aussi
pour les politiques comme notre
président de la république emmanuel
macron est-ce que vous avez des
préconisations à lui donner non belge et
un français
[Musique]
la belgique est d'appeler formidable
avec une culture xtranormal alors je
suis content que les français aiment les
frites nos bières dont du bouffin
seraient bafoués et et tout le reste est
mais je crois que non
ma stratégie toujours et d'exposer pas
d'imposer pas de vendre je montre ce
qu'on a fait j'invite conviennent
quand même voir ce qu'on a réalisé parce
que c'est pour moi la seule chose qui
compte le reste c'est dans le débat un
débat qui tu perds ton temps il faut
aller voir il faut voyager faut être là
où c'est si différent qu'on est prêt
d'ouvrir les yeux et d imaginer
ça paraît simple comme ça mais c'est
simple c'est beaucoup plus simple
pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut toujours
rendre les choses complexes pourquoi
pourquoi ce d'être sujet d étude des pré
études et des défis sybille it is etc
alors là on perd son temps et son argent
nous sommes dans une société qui ne peut
pas prendre des risques et pour pas
prendre des risques on fait quoi on
demande mais kenzy de faire des rapports
sepa meakins hills et ce sont les autres
alors aujourd'hui on est on a des
gérants ont la plus des gens qui créent
et alors pourront malades et gérant ils
ont besoin des consultants
alors question internet comment changer
les mentalités dans ce cas et quels
sacrifices les pays devraient faire pour
mettre en place en place votre modèle
n'est pas de sacrifice c'est à dire vous
avez si vous avez une conscience et un
coeur sont pas des sacrifices c'est un
trans c'est une transformation
alors si on considère transformation
sacrifices ce que je propose c'est
commun dans les modèles qu'on a réalisé
qu'il n'ya plus de chauffage dans les
projets comme el hierro en espagne dans
les projets gaziers en colombie dans les
projets de portail gustin en australie
on a le plein emploi c'est possible
c'est pas au rêve et si en plus on
répond au besoin de tout le monde vous
savez qu'il ya une chose très
intéressante la criminalité n'existe
presque plus si tout le monde est au
travail de démographie comment évoluent
les volumes toujours positif en l'île de
hierro est passé de 6200 déjà à 10500 on
va passer à quinze mille en colombie on
a maintenant une influence des démarré
avec deux sont nés déjà dit mille avec
pourtant goldstein 16 cents à 18 milles
et à voilà on va repasser à 30000 40000
chute une fonction exponentielle non
pourquoi pourrait commencer à
l'expansion latin finit pas d infinies
en crosse de hockey oui mais alors ça
dépend de la largesse du facteur temps
que vous prenez
du coefficient multiplicateur
autre question d'internet l'avènement du
high tech intelligence artificielle
blocs chaîne nous apporte des solutions
sociétale mais ces technologies
coûteuses en énergie ne sont elles pas
en centre
en contre tendance avec blue écologie
absolument le problème c'est que tout ce
qui est autour de l'internet cette
digitalisation a reçu une licence
absolument libre pour
exploiter toutes les sources
énergétiques on veut ah ça c'est
fascinant ont l'internet va passer de 2
à 6 % de consommation totale de
l'énergie dans le monde alors là on a
besoin de l'innovation
mais l'innovation existe connaissez
nakamura le prix nobel
de la led elle vient lui quand il a fait
sa première l'aide il avait 3 % lumière
97%
show température et maintenant il est à
87% lumière il va arriver d'ici deux ans
à 100% ça veut dire que si et maintenant
on fait un mur dger une fusion entre
lumière et internet le plan technique on
a le défi on l'a l'internet par lumière
est ce que vous êtes plutôt et lieu de
masques ou low tech
non je suis les deux ça dépend où alors
on ne peut pas diviser entre l'un et
l'autre j'ai besoin des solutions aux
tec par exemple pour les fermenteurs de
mai algues ou j'ai une productivité des
92 % des gaz méthane ça c'est au tec et
j'en ai besoin le low tech pour faire
pousser des champignons on n'a pas
besoin de grand chose
ici on est en france vos préconisations
g2 on a besoin toujours
7,7 malheureusement cette division entre
noirs blancs pour contre oui non non non
non non c'est tout ça nous sommes une
seat une société qui a besoin quand même
des multiples solutions pour multiples
sociétés multiples comptes
communauté dans multiples régions alors
on peut pas appliquer en alsace ce qu'on
fait en bretagne
les bretons seront d'accord le breton
sont toujours d'accord
est-ce que vous avez des livres a
conseillé trois minimes
j'ai publié sur internet mais 50 livres
qui m'ont espérait alors le plus
important pour moi c'est les mémoires
d'hadrien de marguerite yourcenar
alors là c'est un livre qui devait être
obligatoire pour le monde entier
parce que c'est la réflexion de
marguerite yourcenar
sur les décisions politiques des guerres
qu'a pris l'empereur hadrien et il fait
la réflexion à la fin de sa vie quelles
sont les décisions que le dur aurait dû
prendre qu'il aurait pas dû prendre et
je crois que ce livre qui dans un
français superbe sont six superbes que
seulement le français vaut la peine
c'est ce que les
six les 6 lits alors moi je j'adore le
livre c'est un livre qui m'a beaucoup
marqué
et je crois que c'est sur cet esprit là
que nous devons être l'autre grand livre
c'est l'arbre de la vie de mon père
tomato g
c'est un livre sur la vie sur l'autre
mauvaise sur ce sont des livres
extraordinaires maturana le chilien un
des seuls grands philosophes qui est
encore vivant aujourd'hui la 99 ans
je crois que l'arbre de la vie atteint
est un livre à conseiller au troisième
le troisième
c'est mon livre
c'est un de mes livres que je viens de
sortir si nous soyons aussi intelligente
que la nature
je montre les douces tendances qui sont
dans la nature qui sont tout à fait
naturel dans la nature et je montre les
cas concret qu'on a réalisée en suivant
ce sens dans ce jeudi mais voilà c'est
pas difficile comme home c'est ce qu'on
peut faire et je crois que cette
décision
s'inspirer de la nature
et de voir quelles sont les grandes
tendances de la nature qui nous
permettent d'être sûr fist et de ne pas
nous obligés de créer des vagues je
crois que c'est pour moi un résumé de
mon apprentissage les 42 dernières
années depuis que je suis entrepreneur
et c'est ça je ne peux pas être ni vague
je dois être sûr fist vous êtes plutôt
plus camille ou poly polyandrie ckoi
polygamie plusieurs femmes polyandrie
plusieurs hommes mais non on est on est
né l'année l'autre ont fait le choix
chaque jour
votre question d'internet
à ce que l'énergie est ce qu est ce que
une énergie est vraiment renouvelable si
elle est ici elle utilise des métaux
rares non elle n'est pas tout ce qui
dépendent des sursemis ne sont pas
durables
c'est le problème d'ailleurs avec les
batteries aujourd'hui avec le lithium
alors on le prétend que c'est durable
c'est peut-être recyclables
peut-être recyclables mais à la fin de
la journée c'est pas la solution c'est
l'hydrogène qui est le futur
bah oui il interrogeait un peu le
stocker si facilement et on le paye que
lefebvre dans les fibres et carbon qui
peuvent aussi être naturel alors c'est
là où on a quand même une opportunité
n'oublions pas que huit tonnes le bateau
qu'on à 8 tonnes de lithium fait autant
que 200 kg d'hydrogène alors
l'hydrogène
c'est une belle solution dangereuse
pourquoi aucun l'exclusion ah oui mais
si vous aussi vous
vous passez mal sur la rue une voiture
qui vous rattrape c'est aussi dangereux
il ya plus de personnes qui sont morts
d'une voiture que d'hydrogène alors un
risque on accepte l'autre risque on
n'accepte pas est-ce que vous avez des
préconisations pour résoudre le problème
du terrorisme
je crois que la seule solution pour le
charisme de rassurer que les racines du
tourisme sont plus et ça prend du temps
ça donne transformation s'est changé
c'est que les racines du terrorisme
pauvrété frustration manque de respect
mon de reconnaissance
c'est c'est une société qui ne respecte
pas qui qui qui n'a pas vraiment les
opportunités pour tout le monde et si
vous avez un chômage
parmi les jeunes moins de 26 ans en
moyenne dans quelques pays plus de
75% pour les palestiniens gaza
presque 100 % alors qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je passe ce sont des gens qui
ne voient pas le futur et alors là s'il
est un extrémisme qui qui prétend comme
kittler la prétendue qu'on offre comme
un bleu pouvoir etc vous avez des éclats
qui ne sont pas acceptables qui sont à
condamner mais il faut alors nous
travailler surtout sur les causes les
racines vous croyons qu'en amour a
évidemment tous les jours jusqu'à la fin
de ma vie s'il n'y a pas de l'amour on
n'a pas de coeur alors là il n'y a pas
de vie n'y a pas de danse il n'y a pas
de champ il n'y a rien il n'y a pas de
littérature il n'y a pas de poésie on a
besoin de cet amour vous avez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations
allez rêver du jamais arrêter de rêver
et de ne jamais étudié d'arrêter
d'étudier de faire la chasse aux
diplômes c'est une des plus grandes
erreurs qu'on a tout le monde a ses bacs
tout le monde a ses ses études et tout
le monde sait l'homme contenait des
plots mauvais encore en d'autres
diplômes et contenant un docteur en veut
encore un autre diplôme dire que le mans
et le moment est arrivé aux jeunes de ne
plus leur dhr les diplômes que la
solution pour avoir un beau job il faut
les lancer tous les deux les défis qui
sont dans le monde et dire on n'a pas
réussi c'est alors à vous ce que vous
voulez aborder un sujet particulier avec
nous
l'éducation que l'isi ah oui l'éducation
je crois que la transformation de
l'éducation on a industrialisé
l'éducation je crois que c'est l'un des
plus grands problèmes qu'on passe
aujourd'hui notre société une
industrialisation
standardisation tout est standard et
tout est comparé transparence mondiale
s'est comme fait la concurrence entre
toyota general motors c'était exactement
on traite les étudiants comme une
voiture est alors on fait le test
qualité et on fait des tests minimum je
crois qu'elle l'a et la transformation
la plus importante et je suis
je suis ravi que je fume je suis capable
de partager quelques idées surtout avec
le gouvernement chinois
gunter pauli merci merci à vous
[Musique]
com
m
[Musique]